and Ka Leonard talking to
his Old
Coach shared history between those two
for
sure Clippers six and seven on the
year and we're waiting for Kawai here in
San
Antonio
at they go way
back at
2011.com or follow us on social media
yeah let's send it over to Patrick with
kawhai okay thank you very much Kawai
third straight win it was tough give
them some credit but you guys hang on
what's your takeaway uh you know the
Spurs are always going to fight uh they
don't give up uh they push it till the
end of the fourth quarter and U I mean
it was a good win for us it tested us a
little bit down the stretch a second
quarter something happened that just
doesn't happen in sports when your
former coach papovich addressed the
crowd that just stop booing you just had
a long Embrace what what were you
thinking at at the time when that
happened uh I was focused um I didn't
know if it was him or not I was at the
free throw line but uh you know like you
said uh they're very classy organization
and um I'm pretty sure he wants to keep
it that way lastly you guys have won
three in a row what what makes you think
that your team right now starting to gel
it can maybe you know rattle off a nice
win streak uh just winning winning games
uh I mean winning doesn't always show
you uh that you're getting better but uh
we're happy that we're getting these
wins and we still got a lot to improve
on as you see down the stretch making
careless turnovers and uh you know not
just getting in our spot
thanks for the time and Happy
Thanksgiving appreciate you thank
okay